aujourd'hui si on veut qu'une
comparaison est une certitude qu'il n'y
a pas de lien entre les deux affaires
il faut que je sollicite en vertu des
droits qui sont ceux des parties civiles
et bien une demande de rapprochement
serre que le juge d'instruction de
besançon chargé de la ferme d'aval
demande la communication des
prélèvements adn de la sphère des ce
moulin et les faces comparé par un
laboratoire habilité avec ce alexanian
en scène de crime et autres bois en tant
qu avocat de la partie civile c'est une
demande que vous allez oui je vais
formuler extrêmement rapidement auprès
du juge d'instruction de besançon en
charge et de cerval et seul donneur
d'ordres possible et là il y aura deux
scénarios soit les adn match cela ne
marche pas et si elle match ça change
tout si elle ne marche pas fin de
l'épisode et ce moulin fermeture du
front elle si elle match naturellement
sahour champ des possibles nous devons
ne sais pas il aboutira